we've already shown that we can connect
computers to neurons and we have neural
implants they're actually pretty small
this Parkinson's implant is pea-sized
it's placed actually in the body and
then connected into the brain and you
can download new software to that
computer inside your body connecting
your brain from outside the patient
that's today another one of the
exponential trends is that was shrinking
technology it's actually a rate of about
a hundred and three D volume per decade
so at that rate it won't be pea-sized in
twenty years it'll be blood cell size
and we can send them in through the
bloodstream and so ultimately we can
send these in without surgery but even
with surgery we can attack old more you
know serious brain dysfunction which is
already starting to happen the latest
generation are programmable machines and
the Parkinson's implant first was just
connected to one spot then two and then
four and now they're going for like
hundreds of connections into the
neocortex so we see the same kind of
exponential ramp up but if you're really
going to continue to make progress you
have to basically understand how the
system works it's very hard to fix a
vacuum cleaner if you don't understand
its method of operation the design of
the human brain is contained in the
genome I show in the book there's only
about 25 million bytes of design
information in the genome pertaining to
the brain that's a complicated
derivation but there's that much data in
the genome well so how does 25 million
bison design information create this
entity with hundreds of trillions of
connections through redundancy there's a
great deal of repetition it's like
saying oh a forest is much too complex a
concept for us to understand because
it's got you know trillions of branches
it's millions of trees and every tree is
lots of branches and every branch has
lots of different twists and turns and
not could we possibly understand that
well there's some principles about how a
forest is organized that we can
understand and we can do
easier to understand than the concept of
a tree and I think the brain is easier
to understand than the concept of a
neuron the the basic technologies to
enable us to look inside the brain and
see its functioning are growing
exponentially and there are at a point
now where we can actually see individual
interneural connections forming and
firing we can see your brain create your
thoughts we can see your thoughts create
your brain because that's key to the
secret of its operation that we actually
create the connections that constitute
the hierarchy of the neocortex from our
own thoughts